hey president biden the 1970s called
they want their unmitigated disasters
back yep move over jimmy carter
president biden is looking a lot like
the one-term democrat
every passing day gas lines getting
longer
prices rising everywhere you look chaos
is expanding like one of jensaki's
binders
and all under biden's leadership the
president though has been
reluctant to even talk about it you guys
are bad i'm not supposed to be answering
all these questions i'm supposed to
leave but i
can't resist your questions now here's a
shocker
the gop is blasting biden for the
multiplying crises
the way that they've handled any crisis
in this country is just
disastrous the byte administration needs
to take this seriously
this is important infrastructure for our
country and it could impact our economy
greatly if they don't respond
feels a little bit like the 70s in fact
you start to see gas lines
the concern of what has happened we're
incentivizing people not to work in
america
we need to get people back to work back
to school back to health and back to
normal
where is the president's leadership on
any of these crises
no wonder the democrats and the media
are so obsessed with liz cheney
it sure beats looking at the
catastrophes they've created in just
four short months
of course their idea of a republican
leader is one who agrees with them that
trump is a big evil meanie
yeah liz that's some vision you have for
the party
i'm popular with democrats and yet what
happens
when the evil tweeter leaves you get
inflation
middle east unrest joblessness a
relentless crime wave
historians might call it a malaise and
so now you see the insidious trade-off
from morning joe to don lemon they never
cared about the deeds
it was only trump's hurtful words and
they were happy to replace their
sleepless nights
with your actual material suffering well
congrats media there are no more mean
tweets to keep you up at night
just impending economic doom sleep tight
your selfish babies
so uh dana you know if we're gonna go
back to the 70s i want it all
i want to have saturday morning cartoons
back i want shag carpeting
i want road trips and station wagons
with a chain smoking dad
i want all of that yeah do you want the
station wagon with the seat that went
the face backwards yes
oh i loved harassing the kids that were
facing you when you get behind them on
the freeway
and you you make faces at them and then
and then there was that remember
all those energy subsidies my parents
took advantage of those they put solar
panels on the top of our house
we had a hot rock box downstairs for hot
water i mean we were into it
yeah and yet you know they say history
repeats itself
um sometimes when it repeats itself it's
uh comes back with a vengeance i noticed
that the
one of the headlines in bloomberg today
was biden's gop
opponents seize on rising prices and the
slower than expected pace of hiring when
the headline could have just as easily
been that experts proven right
that printing a bunch of money and
throwing it from the rooftops to
everybody willy-nilly will actually lead
to inflation
yeah that's true that's true i'm always
i always get worried when leaders
urge calm you know uh
jesse if this were a time travel movie
it would be called joe and kamala's
awful adventure
very good first i'm don't know where you
got the idea that i like looking in the
mirror so much
i hate what i see in the mirror it's i'm
very insecure about that
but first i just want to pre-but what
juan is going to say i don't want to
hear about approval ratings juan
the guy's a democrat he's in his
honeymoon period the corrupt media has
his back
if he were a republican with this
portfolio of problems
he'd already be deemed an incompetent
failure if you think about it this way
and i'm going to cover him objectively
as i said i would
he was handed a recovering economy a
vaccine and a distribution plan that was
humming along
a secure border low gas prices and no
inflation
and right now the jobless rate just
ticked up we have a border mess
we have inflation back high gas prices
and the j and j pause
destroyed vaccine confidence and the
vaccination rates
plummeted i'm not even talking about the
rise in homicides or shootings
the concern over school reopenings
i'm not talking about the cost of living
that's gone up
these are just domestic issues think
about internationally too he unfroze the
aid to the palestinians gave him a
quarter billion which they used on
weapons to attack israel
we got hacked by russians we took down
our pipeline
they restarted the nornstream pipeline
and they kicked us out of the black sea
i'm not saying all this is joe's fault
i'm saying he had a hand
in a lot of this and this isn't stuff
like
you know your skin color what the
weather is going to be like in a hundred
years
this is immediate stuff that affects
families schools
illegal immigration crime and the cost
of living
and instead of addressing these things
he's denying them there is no border
crisis
there's no labor shortage there's no
fuel problems
he just denies it he gets away with that
but as the summer comes along
it's going to get hot and all of these
things are going to get exacerbated
we elected a president to solve problems
joe biden is now
creating problems and it's ironic greg
you touched on this with the media
we got joe in the office because we
didn't want any drama
in the white house right well there is
no drama in the white house
the drama is outside of the white house
it's all over the country
and if that's the trade-off that's fine
that's what people want
yeah juan do you care would you care to
pre-but his rebuttal or rebut his
pre-buddle
i don't know how it works uh i'll keep
it i i i do but i'll keep his butt out
of it greg
i think i i
i am listening with amusement because i
can see that
republicans are having a desperate time
going after this popular president
i mean let's let's start you know with
gas
lines right because i live in washington
dc so right here
next door is virginia and there have
been gas lines today
and i see what's going on i think
everybody is talking about the fact that
there was a russian criminal syndicate
uh that hacked into the colonial
pipeline
and that has created this temporary
problem nobody blames joe biden
they great they blame the russian
criminal syndicate and
know that according to the people who
run the pipeline
this problem will be done shortly and i
mean you think about inflation
right now you have higher cost on
used cars things like lumber why because
the economy's taking off it's heating up
and some of the leftover problems from
the pandemic
are still with us and so they're going
to be blips but they're going to be
temporary blips and as far as
foreign policy israel and the arabs
my gosh how many presidents have had to
deal
with flare-ups and hatred between
palestinians
and the israelis i think that goes back
to eisenhower doesn't it
i think what's going on here greg you
touched on it
what's going on here is a big attempt by
republicans to distract
from what's going on in their own ranks
today they canceled
liz cheney and why did they cancel her
because she told the truth about the big
lie
you say oh it's you know people don't
like trump oh no
people know about the big lie they know
about the insurrection and they know
about the damage done to democracy
and they want to have this kind of thing
rooted out but the republican party is
having trouble reconstituting itself
instead it's all the only thing that
seems to bring them together and
coalition is
cult like a affection for donald trump
well you'll i i guess you'll be happy to
know that o.j simpson agrees with you he
came out in support
of her as well so i think we're all in
good company
all right katie uh you can respond to
juan
or you can talk about the facts
inflation is rising fastest
at the fastest pace in 12 years uh
gas prices are at a seven year high and
that was before the pipeline
well i don't know what everybody
expected from a guy who
campaigned from his basement i mean
that's not leadership what we're seeing
now is not leadership
on a day when there are multiple crisis
crises and
multiple fires to put out both
domestically and
on the foreign front national security
front joe biden goes to lectern and
walks away and then says i'm going to
get in trouble for answering your
questions
he's the president of the united states
if there's any day
when he should be answering questions
it's today and then when he's
asked what americans can expect about
gas lines and this the idea that there
are multiple
city major cities on the east coast that
now are
out of gas as a result of a an attack on
the pipeline
he didn't have an answer for them he
said well we need more education that's
not a solution to the the problem that's
happening right now and
all of this is a big test the state
department is in
is in vienna negotiating with the
iranians to talk about getting back into
a nuclear deal
giving them more money to do exactly
what they're doing with hamas
against israel there's a lot of
americans who live in israel israel is
an ally of ours
and if this was a russian attack as the
administration has
said in one way or another what is the
response
was this an act of war how is america
going to stand up and
show strength at a time when they are
testing this president on day 112
and yet this is where we are so weakness
is very clear and the white house is
doing nothing
to stand up for the strength of america
at a time when everybody is watching
yeah i don't think hamas would have been
this brazen
if there was that the orange monster in
the white house hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else